To računam, ovaj, on vroto ga...
Evo se kum.
Sarinu Samune, ovo Sarina 215, da on ga računam, dobro.
Stvarno.
Hvala.
vrednost robne stavke
množi sa carinskom stopom
sa carinskom stopom
da
dobro
a ima neku proveru da ta cifra
bude u ovu tipa
ude goza sa u 215
a šta si rekao, zabagalo na sekundu
provera
Znaš šta možete desi? Da ja unesem carinu za jedan artikl da je 17%, a carina je od carinu na 8%.
Aha.
I sad, onda unesem vrednu carinu ovde, sad je gore, vidiš 211 505.
Jasno, jasno.
A sad na ovom artiklu je 37 000, a trebala da bude, ne znam, 50 000, nebitno.
Jasno.
E sad, šta sam ja pravio u Excelu, da bi se to ne mjeseo, prvi artikali ima carinu 18%, drugi su 8%, ti prema izračunaš carinu koliko treba da bude prema tome, kolika je suma te carine, uporadiš sa ovom carinom kojo je carina naplatila i proporcionalno onda ovu carinom kojo je carina naplatila rasporediš po stavkama.
transport po zapremini je onda već i računa po zapremini
transport po zapremini to ok
i ovi ostali vezani trosku isto treba da idu po zapremini
dobro
to možda nisam promenio da je ostave droškove
Da su oni mnogo sitni, ne moraš da se bakiči oko toga.
U raziči, ne veze, nije ova igra, da radim, radim kako volja.
I to je to onda.
Dobro, menjam to pa te zovem, tim promenim.
Ako ti ti tič artikala, vidi, ti si meni još, ima tome jebiga, možda dve nelje, tri, tako nešto.
Rekao, pošto za sad nemamo toliko proizvoda, da recimo, da kada, ne znam, imamo, ne znam, onu džezvu.
Dobre.
To pojavljuje kao dva proizvoda, ali opet da unutar tih proizvoda mogu ljudi da menjaju.
Da, da, da, tako je.
Možda ti za to malo komplikovano, ono, kad nosiš artikle i porodice, postao si u grupu sliku, onu sinoći.
Da, da.
A šta si štio?
Veze nas...
Cekaj, sad da vidim šta sam poslao.
Zadnju ovu.
E to gore.
Još gore.
Ne, ne, čekaj, sad ću da je to gore na tušku.
Ajde, sajte.
Aha, a ovo sam te pitao zato što si promenio izgled ovoga pa ne znam šta radi
Aha, aha, aha
Da